let's talk about enzymes what would be
the number one symptom that you would
get if you were deficient in digestive
enzymes you're really dealing with about
five different pieces of this puzzle
that you have to understand you have the
stomach you have the pancreas you have
the gallbladder even though the
gallbladder does not produce enzymes
it's involved in enzymes and you have
the small intestine and you have the
large intestine so let's start with the
stomach what enzymes does the stomach
produce well primarily one called pepsin
and pepsin has everything to do with
digesting protein
but the stomach also makes another
enzyme called lipase which can help you
break down fats but only um like a
backup if you don't make it from other
organs we'll talk about that but pepsin
is a very powerful
protein enzyme that helps you break down
protein and pepsin is activated by
hydrochloric acid in the stomach and one
of the big problems with you not having
enough of this enzyme is really not
having enough hydrochloric acid but
maybe you have acid in your stomach but
just the pH is not acid enough and if
you don't have the acid you're not going
to have the release of the enzyme and
you're going to experience uh various
symptoms the number one symptom you're
going to experience is indigestion and
then you're going to get gas those are
the two primary ones but if you're not
digesting protein okay because you don't
have enough acid you're going to have
all sorts of things that are going to
occur lower in the digestive tract for
example
that acid is also necessary to activate
the gallbladder to release bile and if
you don't have that activation then we
don't have enough bile and then we don't
get the necessary detergent to help
extract the fat soluble nutrients from
the fat that you eat and then we have
undigested protein material that ends up
in the small intestine and now both the
pancreas and the small intestine have to
overcompensate and they have to produce
more enzymes to help break down this
material and many times this doesn't
happen so you end up with all sorts of
issues with gas and bloating and
constipation all stemming from this lack
of acid that's supposed to activate and
release the enzyme so typically in this
situation
a lot of people take
um pepsin but they don't take the
hydrochloric acid that's necessary to
activate it so it doesn't really work
that well why are we not producing
hydrochloric acid it could be you're
just getting older because as we age we
don't produce enough hydrochloric acid
it could be because you're taking
antacids that's one big reason why you
don't have enough acid because maybe you
have heartburn which by the way comes
from a lack of stomach acid in the first
place and that valve is not closing so
if the valve doesn't closed you get
regurgitation you get GERD and you can
have a lot of problems as in acid reflux
which could also be caused from a lack
of vitamin B1 as well as a lack of
vitamin D so the first thing that I
would do if I had indigestion
gas is I would take betaine
hydrochloride retain hydrochloride is a
really good simple solution for
activating this enzyme in the stomach to
help you with protein digestion all
right let's shift gears to the pancreas
okay
so if you don't have the full function
of the pancreas you could have what's
called pancreatic enzyme insufficiency
okay so you just don't make enough
enzymes and the majority of enzymes for
digestion actually come from that
pancreas so this is very very important
the pancreas works like crazy to produce
enough enzymes to help you digest food
so based on what you're chewing there's
little signals get sent down to tell the
pancreas to get ready to digest whether
it's fats proteins carbohydrates or
other things and so the pancreas has to
produce that in preparation for the food
that's coming through and then depending
on how much acid you have in your
stomach is whether you're going to
release enough bile
to help work to break down the fats
small enough
so the enzymes the lipase enzymes the
fat enzymes can act on this fat you see
if you don't have enough bile to do the
big work then that lipase enzyme really
is going to have a hard time breaking
down that fat and then you end up with
undigested fat that goes through the
small intestine into the large bowel and
then that symptom which can come from a
pancreas problem is called stiatorea
okay which is undigested fat so you have
this large volume of stool very bad odor
sometimes it's floating sometimes it
leaves skid marks the color could be
anywhere from light brown to pale to
Gray and that can be coming from a lack
of pancreatic enzymes or even a lack of
bile maybe you don't have a gallbladder
maybe you have a bile deficiency maybe
you're just not producing a bile but if
if you're deficient in the enzymes
coming out of the pancreas you're going
to have problems with the digestion of
fat you're going to have bloating you're
going to have abdominal pain and you're
going to have a lack of fat soluble
vitamins
like vitamin A Vitamin K Vitamin E
vitamin D and you can have a lot of
different symptoms from that I almost
forgot to mention if there's a problem
in the stomach and you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid you can be deficient
in amino acids okay and that could be a
big issue with building your muscle and
you may just start losing weight and you
might feel weak now with the pancreas
one common cause of this enzyme
deficiency is pancreatitis
so what could cause that well there's
some rare things like tumors certain
diseases like cystic fibrosis which is a
problem with certain fluids like
digestive fluids or juices like your
mucus in your lung but more commonly
okay what can happen is you have either
gallstones or gall bladder sludge okay
and this sludge is stuck in the pipes in
the bile ducts the bile duct as it comes
out through the liver kind of branches
over into the pancreas and the
gallbladder so if you have a stone or
sludge in these ducts it can back up not
just the gallbladder but the pancreas as
well and it can create all sorts of
inflammation and it's a much more common
problem than other problems
and the solution is something called Tut
cup which is a type of bile salt that
can just open up those ducts because it
allows the sludge to open up and become
thinned okay and you can actually even
help to reduce skull stones with that
and the very reason why you have a
sludge in the first place is maybe
you're on a low-fat diet maybe you're
don't have enough saturated fat in your
diet that actually activates this whole
thing maybe you're eating too many carbs
increasing your insulin maybe uh it's
from too much stress or you're on
steroids for some reasons or you are on
birth control pills because too much
estrogen can create that problem now
another common problem with the pancreas
is that let's say you have diabetes and
you have chronic diabetes and so you
have a big problem with the beta cell of
the pancreas well the pancreas both
produces hormones like insulin and
another hormone called glucagon but it
also half of it is all about enzymes so
being a diabetic can put a big strain on
the digestive part of that pancreas so
one of the best things to do if you know
you have a pancreatic problem is to take
pancreatic enzymes pancreatin is a group
of pancreatic enzymes you can take in a
supplement and that can take a huge
strain off your digestion and help you
and if you were to take that I would
also recommend you take betaine
hydrochloride to have the complete
package and probably wouldn't hurt to
also take with that some ox bile so
let's now shift gears to the gallbladder
the gallbladder is also going to help
you extract facil nutrients because the
bile that's made by the liver and stored
in the gallbladder concentrates so every
time you eat it's squeezed out and it's
going to go into the small intestine and
help as a part of this digestive Synergy
between the stuff that's coming out of
the stomach into the small intestine and
then the help from the pancreas that
lipase from the pancreas is like the
icing on the cake it helps to fully
break down that fat so you have to
complete digestion of fat and even
though the gallbladder doesn't produce
enzymes it really contributes to these
other enzymes and it's a really common
problem and a lot of people have a
problem with it a lot of people don't
have enough bile some common symptoms of
that would be bloating belching and
burping not to mention a lack of fat
soluble nutrients vitamin A d e and K
but also you can notice a pain in your
right shoulder right through and here
that goes up into the neck or that wraps
around into like in the rhomboid area
and a fullness underneath your right rib
cage now let's move right down to the
small intestine okay
ninety percent of all your digestion
occurs in the small intestine
your small intestine actually make
enzymes as well normally you're not
supposed to have a lot of bacteria in
your small intestine compared to the
large intestine so primarily we want the
help from the enzymes and so depending
on what's happening at the stomach level
and the pancreatic level and the
gallbladder is going to determine how
hard that small intestine has to
compensate or work or release these
enzymes so all these organs are working
in Synergy together now let's just for
example say that you don't have enough
strong stomach acid okay and that's one
of your problems
well a lot of bacteria in the food can
get through because now it can't be
killed because that's one of the key
functions of of that acid to prevent uh
microbes from going through but now we
get these microbes that go through there
and they end up in a small intestine
where they shouldn't be there
and also because we don't get the
signaling from the gallbladder to
release bile salts so it's both the acid
and the bile salts to act strongly on
that small intestine to ensure that
there's not a lot of bacteria that grow
in that small intestine too and so now
we have an increase of bacteria in the
small intestine that can then reproduce
and grow and develop into what's called
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth I
mean one function of bile salts is to
act as a detergent to kill off these
microbes in your small intestine and
then when you when it gets all the way
down to the last part of the small
intestine it gets reabsorbed and it
starts over again so it's a really
important action to prevent sibo the
same thing with hydrochloric acid so now
we end up with this sibo what is the
problem with sibo small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth
wow you have bloating you have belching
you have abdominal pain and now you also
have competition from these microbes
that are hungry and they're going to eat
a lot of your nutrition from your food
so you're going to end up with all sorts
of nutritional deficiencies malnutrition
digestive issues and the fiber that you
eat is going to be fermented at the
wrong place in the small intestine
instead of the large intestine so now we
get a worsening problems when you have
your salads and you get worsening
problems with gas going down the other
end and we get worsening problems if you
take a probiotic because you're adding
more bacteria so it becomes a big issue
how can we solve that well there are
certain tests that you can do to
identify if that's your problem but the
solution is to start taking
retain hydrochloride to fix the stomach
the solution is to start taking some ox
bile to help with the gallbladder cut
down the amount of fiber that you
consume in fact I would do carnivore for
a while and also do routine intermittent
fasting and you can do also do other
things like you could take a natural
antibiotic like garlic for example that
would be something that can help kill
off these microbes it's not going to be
as important as those two other actions
now what about the large intestine does
your large intestine produce enzymes and
the answer is no but the microbes the
Flora the microbiome do produce a lot of
different enzymes to help you with
digesting a lot of things especially
things that you can't digest like fiber
so they're working hard to digest this
and they also digest certain leftover
sugars and even leftover proteins if you
don't have enough of the right microbes
the diversity this is where you get
diarrhea constipation and of course a
fatty stool that's something that floats
it has a very bad odor and so the best
solution would be to fortify
the microbiome if you don't have sibo
you can feed a wide variety of different
plant leaves or plants to help increase
that diversity you can also take a
probiotic which I would highly recommend
or consume fermented foods that have
probiotics of course only if you don't
have sibo I hope that answers uh some of
the questions on your digestive tract
but this leads me to the next thing what
is the most underlying important thing
you can do to prevent all of these
issues and for that answer I put this
video up on just implementing the right
diet right here check it out